so first I kind of wanted to paint a
picture of when this whole idea came up
for you did you already have the idea
before things with the dark universe
kind of went in a sour direction not at
all I mean I was very aware of this
character obviously he's a part of pop
culture but I had no desire to make an
invisible man film so then you come up
with the idea immediately after that
possibility went away didn't ya I just
finished upgrade okay and I was really
happy with the way upgrade turned out
and I kind of got bit by the action
movie bug I wanted to crash some cars
blow some things up and I went in for a
meeting with you know some of the Blum
House and universal execs and this
character was floated it was like what
do you think about the Invisible Man
I was pretty mystified as to why we were
talking about that character in
particular but immediately I started
thinking about these opportunities to
modernize the character and make him
scary for a modern audience was there
any hesitation after having so much
success with upgrade your own original
idea jumping back into something that
was I guess an adaptation or a new spin
on an iconic character yeah maybe for a
second but I realized that I could put
my own spin on it I could take this
iconic beloved character and wrap
something around it that felt like my
film you kind of have to Jedi mind trick
yourself into thinking that this is the
first time an Invisible Man stories ever
been told you know I don't want to think
about all the other versions of this
character that have gone before whether
it's TV shows movies I just want to
forget all that and think you know how
would this movie play if this was the
first time this story was being told so
know what advice would you give someone
else out there because we're bound to
see not necessarily another Invisible
Man movie but more maybe with the
Universal Monsters coming back to screen
what would advice what advice would you
give for a writer and director jumping
into that well well look personally in
my own humble opinion I think these
characters have to get back to their
roots they were scary when they first
came out and I think that a lot of these
iconic monsters Dracula the Wolfman
they've become so ubiquitous in pop
culture that it's drained all the power
out of them what I would want to do and
or what I would want to see with
characters like that is for them to
become scary again like Dracula is
supposed to be terrifying you know now I
watch cartoons where he's voiced by Adam
Sandler right it's it's more of a it's
more of a cartoonish thing now the cape
and the voice I think I think there is a
way to make these characters scary again
that's why they've lasted so long in the
popular imagination because they have
these attributes about them that stick
in our minds you know and it's about
stripping it back to that you've got to
strip it back to its core idea if you
want to make it scary success here it
was scary got under my skin and I took
it with me so thank you for that a
couple other questions for you
spiral do you have anything to do with
that no I have not had anything to do
with the soar films for quite a while
obviously I'm still friends with a lot
of the people involved yeah but I've
really taken a back seat it's a strange
thing to sort of create a movie and then
watch it go off into the wilderness
without you and well also with Chris
Rock and Sam Jackson what was your first
reaction when you heard that's the
direction the franchise was going I'll
tell you I was on a location scout for
this movie and I got a phone call from
one of the guys at Lionsgate who's a
friend of mine and when he told me about
Chris Rock I thought back to a couple of
years ago I was at a film festival party
at the Palm Springs Film Festival and my
agent much to my horror pushed me
towards Chris Rock and was like say hi
to Chris I think I said something lame
like I'm a big fan and he hears that
hundred times a day so he was like okay
and as he was walking away his agent
said to him that guy rode saw and he
like stopped in his tracks came back and
was like you wrote saw and suddenly he
was super interested and he said to me I
would love to make a soar film and I
thought it was just something that you
say in a party you know like hey I'd
love to dye my hair pink
too you just say it because the person's
got pink hair you don't wanna make them
feel bad turns out he was serious that
was not that was not an offhand thing
that he said he really did want to make
a soar film so that was the first thing
I thought about when I heard the news
was Wow Chris Rock wasn't joking I'm so
excited about that if I could squeeze in
one more we have a
lot of Aquaman fans a Collider and I
have been forced to ask this question
it's a burning question the team has
what do you think your character does
after two people jump out of his plane
like that what's the rest of his day
like I think I think he lands the plane
and assumes a different identity
different job he's just like you know
what I've got a whole backstory for this
cargo pilot that I don't want to reveal
here but I feel like a whole movie this
could spin off into its own universe I
think the cargo pilot is unexplored
territory listening James